does not take holy scripture literally.
Adam and Eve are not our ancestors.
No man descends, Darwin says.
We descend from monkeys and trees.
I should like to ask Mr. Darwin
if it's through his mother's line or his father's.
Or the two.
Dear, oh dear.
Charles Darwin published his famous work
on the evolution of species through natural selection
in 1859.
As you might guess, it caused a sensation.
We know now, of course,
There is natural selection, and species evolve.
They change over millions of years.
But back in those days...
Look at me. I'm an evolved species.
I'm a monkey's uncle.
You're still mostly monkey, in my opinion.
Darwin revolutionized our ideas and how we originated.
There was nothing about him that was revolutionary.
For instance, in his youth.
And as our illustrious predecessors have amply shown,
the blood is pumped by the heart.
Strong, young man.
Mr. Darwin, what are you doing?
Catching these insects, Professor.
The ones we collected with Mr. Henslow, the professor of natural science.
And what exactly do you think you will achieve, bringing bugs to an anatomy lesson?
Are you really interested in medicine?
That's what I've been wondering as well.
What is it? Do you see something special in that insecto?
Yes, Professor Henslow.
If you will observe, near the back legs, there is a small orifice, a small hole.
If this beetle is attacked, it can squirt out a substance to defend its size.
It might be an acid, an irritant.
It might be.
Definitely. Well observed, Darwin.
Look over there. No doubt you recognize it as tussock grass. It's quite interesting.
Would you mind bringing me back a sample?
Yeah, sure, sir.
In your education, there is a...
You should take geology, and then you might have a better idea about the soft soil and riverbeds.
The Reverend Sedgwick, professor of geology, which is the study of the Earth, of course.
Now, the Earth was created exactly 6,024 years ago.
But how can we know the precise dates, sir?
Always asking such stupid questions.
It says so in the Holy Bible. Didn't you ever read Genesis?
Yes, sir, only I'm sure I never saw the date of creation written there.
The date young man will deduce from events mentioned in the Bible.
I'd have thought that obvious. Are we not guided by Holy Scripture?
Oh, yes, we are, sir. We most certainly are, sir.
So, Charles, you want to follow in my footsteps and be a doctor?
Somehow, I just don't feel it's right for me, Dad.
Ah, pity.
Well, then, Charles, all that's open is law and theology.
Yes, you might make a preacher. It's an honorable profession.
Suppose we discuss it after the holidays.
Professor Henslow!
What a pleasant surprise finding you here.
I came especially to see you, Charles.
There's a wonderful opportunity, and it's perfect for you.
Dee?
Yes, thanks.
In a word, Charles, a ship of the Royal Navy is to be sent to explore the coast of South America
to make a sea chart, well, a map,
and Captain Fitzroy wants a naturalist to go along on the expedition
and take note of the plants and animals of those regions.
Naturally, I recommended you.
Yes, but am I really going to be fully capable of it?
I mean, and would my father agree?
My advice, Charles, is go and see the captain that departures from Plymouth in the autumn.
Yes, but...
This voyage is utter foolishness, Charles.
You should complete your studies.
Get married.
I won't forbid your going, but you will lose a great deal of time.
I promise you, I'll think about it.
Certain details.
You go into the observations.
Sort of transformation.
Protect our citizens.
Summon more armed men from the ship.
Could we have better let us talk in here?
I have drinks in the cooler.
It's true, thank you, our English composure.
And I might mention, my lad, you did very well in the battle.
First rate for a naturalist.
Into the interior, though, be sure to take a weapon, because you never know.
A full-grown sloth, and not afraid of humans.
Just like armor.
But three times as big.
We'll take the bones back with us.
It is curious.
It's as if, over time, a species is transformed.
It got much smaller.
Aren't species set down once and for all in nature?
It's of Terra del Fuego, cast anchor!
Survivors of the flood in the Bible? I'm not so sure.
But what else could they be?
Surely you wouldn't question holy scripture.
Trigid, yet quite much smaller. It only has three toes.
The neck and head covered with feathers. I have to know why.
Christmas Day, no traditional Christmas goose, but we have this magnificent, uh, what do you say, it's called?
Anandu.
Yes, of course, that's it. We'll name it Darwin Inandus in your honor.
Let us give thanks to the Lord, with chart in heaven, hallowed be thy name.
The Straits of Magellan are dangerous at any time.
Look at that!
You're beginning to get the hang of it.
Where's Teddy?
Captain?
And we're on course for the Galapagos, a small group of islands of no special interest,
but they have to be put on our chart.
I believe there's even a governor there.
Three days! I'll study these curious creatures.
'Cause they take refuge on dry land.
They swim like finchinated and sure he's from the water.
Great pleasure to welch you find the tea to your liking.
Strange. These finches seem to be identical, but their beaks differ.
That's because they are from different islands.
Now, that is strange. I must see this for myself.
We'll stay here and observe the finches.
Finches eat only insects and caterpillars, you see?
And their beaks are thin. Let's observe another island.
They have different beaks. Beak is adapted to the food.
Naturally, the creator knew what he was doing.
We must be off. It's time to sail home.
Consider the time you've wasted.
And you will be so good as to shave off that unfortunate beard.
you mean you don't recognize me charles uh oh yes certainly janice how are you no guess again
susan cousin in shrewsbury wrong again it's true i was just a little girl when you left
emma emma wedgewood how stupid of course well you're all grown up now look here why don't we
take a stroll in the garden it's so warm tonight to voyage all the wild animals you must have seen
gorillas no there weren't gorillas not in the america well then why there were sloths and
armadillos sea elephants as well as iguanas conjures snakes that's what i saw what is it
did i scare you no no charles but something's crawling on where let me see told you my ankle
out of the question charles then it will just bite you oh no charles tiny look nice my ankle
You shouldn't say such things, Charles.
Yes, it's a beetle.
Yes, look here. It's a corpus lunares.
They're rare this early in springtime.
See how his protonium is rounded.
See its elitrons. Nine stripes, no less.
Charles and Emma will get married and settle down in this pretty place near London.
They're there to live happily for many years and have many children.
Yes, sir, and he, Mrs. Darwin, are fine.
Marvelous. Please tell Mrs. Darwin I'll be right there.
I've almost finished here.
Charles, sir, Charles, it's a girl.
Marvelous, I'll be right there.
Oh, there were to be eight in all.
Over the next 20 years, Charles Darwin rarely left his study.
He's elaborating the theory that will make him famous, the theory of evolution.
Emma, I'm an inattentive husband, I know that.
Charles, I am perfectly contented with you.
I know that what you are doing is important, and so I do what I can.
It's nearly complete, my theory of evolution, and I know it's right.
What is it exactly?
Well, now, you've seen giraffes.
When we take the children to the zoo.
Yes, quite so.
Well, giraffes live in arid zones of Africa, very dry.
When grass becomes scarce, they eat leaves from treetops, which the other animals can't reach.
Many naturalists, like the Frenchman Lamarck, believe the giraffes acquire long necks because they stretch them,
and so their offspring are born with long necks.
But that's not how it happens. Not at all.
In every species of animal, and humans too, there are slight variations, hardly noticeable ones.
With a giraffe, when grass is scarce, the ones with longer necks are more fit to survive.
And the trade is passed on.
That's what I call natural selection.
Humans?
At one time, his species didn't exist at all.
Earth is older than 6,000 years, as claimed by the Bishop of Usher.
Man, no doubt, evolved from a species like this.
He Charles?
No, not precisely.
A sort of missing link between us and the ape.
Earlier, it evolved from the monkey.
Charles, the work you've done is remarkable.
Your theory of natural selection is excellent.
You have to be published.
Yes, my friend, but I must be absolutely sure this time, before I publish.
I can still recall the laughter when I proposed the idea that a bear,
swimming with its mouth open over several thousand years, would turn into a whale.
Oh, my friend, it was an error of youth.
Who hasn't made them? That's all for God now.
All the same, do you recall Coney Barron's attack on Lamarck's theories?
Scorn and ridicule.
Let us consider this theorist, this upstart, this imposter,
It's Lamarck with his ridiculous speculations.
All these abominations are pure absurdities of reason.
And my friend, your eminent colleague, Reverend Sedgwick,
remember what he said of Lamarck's theories.
I detest such theories.
They are cold, materialistic, and to be rejected out of hand
because they exclude any notion of a divine creator.
So you understand my reserve if my theory of natural selection
and evolution of species is an insult to God?
So as Darwin hesitates, afraid to publish his theory, another naturalist, Alfred Russell Wallace, is studying living species in Asia.
Observe. In the struggle for survival, those animals best adapted to their environment are more likely to survive as are their descendants who inherit their traits.
So it is species evolved by natural selection the best adapted.
He's evolved the same principle of evolution through natural selection.
Charles, you can't wait any longer. You must publish.
But my book's not finished.
Mr. Darwin, as a geologist, categorically, I endorse everything you say in the light of all our research concerning the Earth.
Very well, I'll publish, but only the first three volumes. It is my intention...
Read all about sensational according to a naturalist, Charles Darwin, man, is really a monster. Read all about...
Did you say the latest? We're all descended from apes. Charles Darwin says...
Blash for me. Darwin insults the almighty himself. Something must be done.
Yes, monseigneur, I will demolish Darwin and his theory.
Just do it.
There is a meeting at Oxford in a few days.
You will see, Monseigneur.
As we all know, our law, the divine architect,
has created a perfect world for man's happiness.
And I submit that Mr. Darwin's theory is not only blasphemous, it is ridiculous.
As we all know, the earth was created 6,000 years ago,
according to the Bishop of Usher,
in the light of his biblical studies and science,
the handmaiden of our mother, Church, has no right to stray off the path.
Huxley, naturalist, may I suggest the Bible was written for simple people of the time.
Its language is not that of science.
Galileo proved this when he demonstrated that the Earth goes around the sun and not the contrary.
Lyle, geologist, member of the Royal Society,
I may assure you that the Earth is millions of years old and not...
We are all well aware of your fame, Mr. Lyle.
Very well, then. Man is descended from monkeys.
Mag, I ask, whether in Mr. Darwin's case, whether it's from his grandfather or his grandmother.
There can be no dishonor, Mr. Wilberforce, in descending from a monkey.
However, it is quite dishonorable to have as an ancestor a man who, to gain for himself
a facile advantage, would take a tone of irony concerning a science about which he knows
nothing and whose only argument is religious prejudice.
The first edition of The Origin of Species is sold out.
I'll have to print another edition.
I think it could be a successful.